hey what is up guys I'm KB HD here and
this is the Chromebook pixel easily one
of the most confusing products of the
first half of 2013 and one of the most
difficult to review because so many of
the products we look at all the time are
geared for consumers this one is not
anyway in terms of pure aesthetics this
thing is awesome it's made of an
aluminum chassis and has a very squared
off design in fact it bears some
resemblance to the 13-inch retina
MacBook Pro in more ways than one but
that's probably a good thing because
they both look pretty good and the
design is all topped off with this sweet
light bar that Google says is included
simply because it looks cool and it does
the design is so understated otherwise
that the light bar is an awesome but
subtle lighting effect that brings the
other the whole Google design like a
boss it's a nice looking accessory and
outside of that it's a very handsome
notebook again we like the aluminum
unibody stuff and the port layout is
also pretty basic we have some USB ports
we have an SD card reader but all that
is to be expected from a basic laptop
now if I were to recommend a Chromebook
to anyone
I recommend the 64 gig LTE model but
this here is a Wi-Fi only version so
it's a 32 gigabyte pixel even so if I
spend $1300 on a laptop any laptop it
better have a nice keyboard a nice
trackpad and nice display might better
heat you know nice build quality the
whole nine I expected the most when you
go over $1,000 and the Chromebook pixel
actually does deliver that
so this Chiklis style keyboard is very
comfortable to type on with you know big
hands small hands it has just a tiny bit
of flex in the center but it's not too
bad and the speakers are incredible like
mind-blowing ly good they happen to be
invisible because they're hidden beneath
the keyboard but they are really really
loud so you can watch a movie literally
in a loud environment with them and
they'll be loud and crisp and clear
they're awesome and the trackpad is also
magnificent this large smooth matte
black trackpad is pleasing to the eye
and very pleasing to use it's nice and
smooth and it completes the laptop
experience and then of course it's
called the Chromebook pixel because of
that display so this guy is rocking a
pretty noteworthy display it's a twelve
point eight five inch 2560 by seventeen
hundred display which makes it
noteworthy for a couple of reasons
1 this is the highest pixel density
display on any laptop at 239 PPI it also
is noteworthy because of the brightness
400 nits very bright display it's
extremely sharp and crisp and clear it's
also noteworthy because it's a 3 by 2
aspect ratio which makes it taller than
your typical 16 by 9 net laptops that
were used to but then again you're
building a machine for the web so every
single web page Scrolls vertically so
you're actually getting some generous
extra vertical pixels in there even if
you do get some letterboxing with movies
so that extra screen real estate is
welcome and it's noteworthy because it's
a touchscreen now I have very mixed
opinions about touch screens on laptops
my number one problem with them is
usually how much the hinge wobbles when
I try to touch the screen on the pixel
is no exception so I found myself
holding the back of the display in place
while I use the other hand on the
touchscreen but I can still use the
keyboard to type regular things but the
other problem is the lack of anything
touchscreen optimized and Chrome OS is
no exception at least right now a lot of
people express the desire for this
device to run Android in one of my
previous videos in the comments section
and that seems to make sense but I'll
get to that in a second so speaking of
Chrome OS how is the operating system
well it's very similar to what we've
seen on those cheaper 200 and 250 dollar
Chromebooks and probably the web browser
you're watching this in right now this
is a pretty advanced version of Chrome
OS though and it has some neat tricks to
make it feel like a little bit more than
just a web browser
first of all multiple window action is
always nice and window management is now
built-in and it works well there's also
this bar at the bottom that feels like
the dock in Windows 7 where you can pin
and launch your applications and you can
also auto hide it too with just a swipe
so that's nice there's also a setting
strafe floating at the bottom right hand
corner and this gives you quick access
to settings and things like volume
Bluetooth etc kind of like Android was
for tablets and I can see this going
further into that direction in the
future as a performer the pixel was
pretty solid in fact it felt like it was
overall a bit more stable than the
Chrome Beta is for my desktop and a few
benchmarks pretty much confirm that it
scored a lot higher on browser mark than
the cheaper Chromebooks but still less
powerful than the hackintosh pro that
runs Google Chrome also of course since
its Chrome OS and boots superfast and it
wakes from sleep instantaneously and all
that stuff
you can go pretty much from a cold boot
to surfing internet in a matter of
seconds
battery life is again very average for a
laptop of this size coming in at about
five-and-a-half hours from my use but
watching a movie on that display could
kill it a bit faster at maximum
brightness but honestly this is like the
ultimate grandma surf the web machine
though it feels very much like a beta
product pinch-to-zoom for example is
buried in the settings in chrome flags
but once it's enabled you can start
playing around with it you can see it
works pretty well on a lot of sites
scrolling is 100% smooth all the time
it's actually common to see that core i5
and its integrated graphics hiccup a
little bit when trying to scroll down
really big sites but for the most part
websites loaded quickly and scrolling
and zooming was a pleasure so you can
tell it really you can tell really
easily which parts of websites aren't
Retina display optimized with certain
graphics and things like that but text
always looks good whenever you zoom in
on text on this display it looks
extremely crisp and sharp from any
viewing distance so really my only
complaint about the Chromebook itself
would be that it gets a bit warm
sometimes when using it for a long
period of time and sometimes that
display is just a bit too glossy the
reflections might get annoying and
daylight but outside of that it's
arguably the best hardware in the
business right now but not Google now
Google has like a really massive task
ahead of them to get chrome OS up to
speed and to get the Chrome OS webstore
up to speed even though Google Drive can
replace Microsoft Office and a lot of
the webstore apps are really well done
right now apps like Photoshop and video
editing apps for example and native
software are really irreplaceable still
and most people would opt for something
running Windows or OS 10 over a
Chromebook every time because the
ability to run native apps but Google
I'll tell you something right now if you
want to make a little money yeah I'll
let you in on a secret if you give the
Chromebook pixel the ability to run
Android apps prepare yourself to sell
out because that would be a real
unlocker
of the potential of this machine but in
the end it is really difficult to
summarize the Chromebook pixel in any
sort of concise way but basically I
would say it goes back to the explained
video that I did a couple of days ago
I'll have a link right below the like
button on this video or you can click
the annotation right there but this is
basically the definition of a
a lo product and I would say as a
summary this is a beautiful piece of
engineering a really good-looking
solidly built piece of hardware that you
should never buy that being said
definitely go watch the explained video
because this is the real definition of a
halo product right here and it's
something that will basically be a
beacon of light and shine the way
forward as a sort of an inspiration for
where Google wants their partners to go
now so like we said we've seen lots of
very cheap $250 $200 Chromebooks now
that have proven that Chrome OS can be
great for a basic cheap computer but
Google is trying to shine the way for
high-end Chromebooks and basically we'll
just see how it goes from here so that's
the Chromebook pixel guys thanks for
watching definitely be sure to subscribe
if you want to see more videos like this
it's definitely helps out a lot and if
you leave a thumbs up that's also very
helpful either way thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you guys the next one
you